I am bringing major spoilers for the
final season of Game of Thrones so if
you don't want anything spoiled it's
time for it to close this video okay as
most of us know for the final season of
Game of Thrones a production for the
very first time instead of filming
King's Landing scene Cindy browning they
decide to make a huge King's Landing set
in Belfast so why did they build set
buildings to resemble the city they used
for King's Landing all these leaders
instead of filming at actual medieval
old town says they usually do that's
because Game of Thrones is not allowed
to burn cities to the ground as the
construction for King's Landing set
focused on polishing the city walls
inside a set streets a famous Dubrovnik
landmark has been faithfully reproduced
the most notable are the city gates and
the King's Landing don't however the set
has recently been modified to appear
burned down with a huge bridge between
demolish towers the city gate has been
obliterated in the towers that was
protected it have fallen the lines
through banners that once the door the
walls are gone King's Landing dome has
been burned down this is the final
confirmation that the capital is most
definitely going to fall and the big
portion of it is going to burn down in
the final season and is speculated for
months now the main suspect behind it
all is the dragon who's also been
spotted on the set yes dragons for
visual effects magic mostly however when
performers have to interact with dragons
a number of methods are used to make it
work
for example if Danny had to touch the
dragon's head any dragon head shaped
object will do this was when dragons
were small this is the netting touching
vissarion's head in the last season for
flying scenes Emilia Clarke uses a
dragon shaped buck which moves in all
the way says wind is directed in a face
effector set actually mount the dragon
part of its spine has to be physically
recreated which is exactly what his
massive conception is King's Landing
said being burned down means that they
are denied king with his Aryan or
Daenerys with dragon will at one point
decide to burn down the capital this
massive contraption being on this very
same set means that once again neither
Danny or the knight King will at some
point decide to land in King's Landing
now that we know for certain that
capital will fall at some point let's
see how it could actually go down these
leaks could be a confirmation of a
theory of mine regarding the night king
and his master plan that will eventually
resulted Circe's and Jamie's death and
even possibly with the death of Jon Snow
in that very I explained you have all
main characters in Game of Thrones as
well as all of us fans expect the great
battle to be fought in the north on a
front defined by the advance of the army
of the Dead and partly we are correct
the north who faced 100,000 strong army
of white walkers center
White's but the night king of life is
Aryan to the first south across the old
Westeros and will raise the dead does
the entire continent will be facing a
horde of White's overnight this theory
of mine has not only been foreshadowed
multiple times throughout the show but
it's also supported with a few visions
from the future that are yet to come
true the shadow of a dragon flying over
King's Landing and one in which brain
sees King's Landing in winter with an
empty throne room that has its rublon
off the same 1 denier so in the house of
the undying basically the night king
will create a huge army in the south
while sacrificing his current army in
the north but let's get a bit back in
the season 7 finale is revealed to Jamie
that you're only pretended to be heading
back to Pike out of fear when here
actually sailed to Essos to Hart the
golden company and to bring them at his
urn fleet Westeros to serve under her
commands this is not coming as a huge
surprise since in the fourth episode of
the season Circe revealed her intentions
to take out a new loan from the arrow
bank to Hart the golden company to
expand her armies with their help starts
to take the advantage of the war between
the living and the dead and we try to
retreat the lands that are currently
taken away from her basically while the
living are fighting the dead search
civil charters she calls it retrieve
kingdoms that belong to her with the
mercenary organization in the far north
on the other hand the knight King has
brought down a large section of the wall
at east watch along his army to march
south although most of Westeros has
agreed to unite and send their forces
north to fight against the only enemy
that matters so we all expect Great War
to take place in the north and will
expect Cersei to quietly rebuild her
power while the fighting happens
elsewhere well we might be wrong now
that the knight King is in possession of
a dragon and no longer has to worry
about the wall he will most likely cause
devastation across the whole Westeros
not only the north the leader of White
Walkers can now fly anywhere investors
relatively quickly and he can raise the
dead not only is this a place where
people in most cases don't burn the dead
but due to recent Wars ravaging Westeros
there are plenty corpses slaying in mass
graves as already said all main
characters expect the great battle to be
fought in the north and a front defined
by the advance army of the Dead and
partly there correct the north will face
a hundred thousand strong army and White
Walkers Center whites but the 19:05 is
Arian to the far south across the whole
Westeros and will raise the dead thus
the entire continent will be facing
horde whites over night now you might be
wondering how is this event even
confirmed but give me a few moments
explained to you while prophecies in
Game of Thrones don't literally come
true visions on the other hand do we
know this for a fact as in the sixth
episode of the sixth season after Muir
flees the cave brain brain receive
multiple visions of the past
future events and one of his visions for
the future already came true in the
season six finale Ren's vision of the
exploding wildfire already came true
at certain Khyber news at four episodes
later to destroy the great Sept of
Baelor with majority of her enemies the
remaining two visions from the future
daria to capture the shadow of a dragon
flying over King's Landing and the one
image brain sees King's Landing in
winter with an empty throne room that
has its rule enough at first glance this
would imply that Danny doesn't up
reaching and taking over King's Landing
eventually but the crumbled building the
Red Keep and burned houses with the
wintry background are of the major
importance then he would not destroy the
red cape in which the iron turn is nor
would she burn down houses very innocent
people live a spurring numerous season
seven seats the damage done to the red
keep into the houses however it's
consistent with something that Danish
dragons would be able to do the main
suspect being her dead dragon bazarian
these brans visions one of which Danny
had as well along with leaked photos in
which we can see that big portion of
King's Landing will at some point be
burned down pretty much confirm my
statement that the night King of five is
area to the far south and raise the dead
across solo Westeros thus leaving stars
explained quite a bit ruined and also
surprising the entire living side while
the leader White Walkers is forming an
army across all Westeros his current
army that has in the season seven finale
finally crossed into the Northville in
the season 8 premiere hit and destroyed
castles of house amber and house
Karstark just as John in season 7
premiere said they would if the wall
Falls
someone think that his army would be
destroyed once it comes across
Winterfell but leaked photos seem to
provide wise now we're coming to
long-anticipated sources downfall and
death that be caused by her becoming the
met Queen upon suffering the tremendous
defeat by the current army of the dead
just of Dany and crow will retreat south
to here at the Riverland sword avail
however tabled and learned that the
knight King has formed an even bigger
army of the Dead in south bran stark
will inform them that the netting is
marching his new army in King's Landing
upon learning this just now Danny and
the entire living side will decide to go
to the Capitol to face the great and
final battle and thus help Cersei
defended since its large city with a
population of 1 million innocent people
all main characters being a teens
landing at some point of the final
season has been confirmed by leaked
photos as well even though John and the
entire living side is coming to Cersei
Zaid she is preparing a trap for them
Circe intends to have all her enemies
both the living and the dead to fight on
streets of King's Landing while she
would use wildfire to burn them all you
might be wondering why would not the Met
Queen instead of burning everything down
use this meeting as an opportunity to
capture and kill her living enemies and
then tried rarely the living side and
fight the night king with or without
John Snow their armies who still have to
fight and try to win the great war
soldiers to use this opportunity to get
rid off of one of her enemies the answer
is yes she would most certainly like to
do that but no she will not be able to
capture and execute John like she didn't
start the reason being the nearest
regain his presence it's not only John
who came to parley with Cersei he's
accompanied by Danny Wallach photo shows
a figure silhouetted in an archway the
figures seem to be Danny herself as the
figure has blonde hair dark outfit and
chain across the front it looks the same
to what Danny was wearing glass season I
know that you're wondering so why won't
Cersei then capture both the John and
Danny for that matter the answer is one
small detail they're having a parley in
front of a window edge by showing to
prevent spoilers sent this was horrible
way to do it
so filming this major seen from the
window must be of the great necessity
for the scene and now we're coming to an
answer that will explain to you why
Cersei will not be able to use this
opportunity to capture enemies it's
because of Danish dragons at some point
the filming crew set green-screen across
that window meaning that Cersei will
have a clearer view on Daniel Dragons
flying above King's Landing and
therefore if she's to capture and
execute any of them Cersei knows that
the Danish dragons send armies will
attack and defeat her search this plan
at this point is to welcome the living
side into the capital and pretend to
agree that they shall face the common
enemy together search this plane is
awaiting the red cape for the army of
the Dead to breach the city walls sent
for the great battle to take place
inside the capital
Cersei would then burn down all her
enemies the living and the dead using
wildfire it's still unknown whether or
not sources of air that there's caches
of wildfire under the red keep itself
even though it would not be surprising
if she does when faithfully feeds her
similar certainly would not hesitate to
blow up King's Landing even if it means
she would die as well don't forget that
when it appeared that Stannis was
winning the battle for King's Landing
Cersei was ready to kill herself along
with her child
Oh sir she managed to pull it out and
burn everyone down even though burn
King's Landing set would seem to support
this theory the answer is no wildfires
not the reason King's Landing set is
being burned down it's Dragon Fire how
do I know it's simply due to a fact that
the show built a King's Landing set
mainly to do liepard techniques it means
that some parts of the capital will be
burned down by a dragon a dragon fire
and Game of Thrones is portrayed by live
pyrotechnics basically searched this
plan to have the living and the dead
fight inside the King's Landing will
come true
but her burning them all it's wildfire
will not and I think it could have
something to do with
her brother Jim Lee encircle read say
the city from wildfire before Jamie
saved King's Landing from the Mad King
will he be the one to save it from the
met Queen as well maybe one is CERN huge
portion of King's Landing will be burned
down by a dragon in final season it will
be the night king and he's done that
dragon will the nearest at some point is
site over trousers India's Geoghan and
Rea goal to achieve it will this be the
result of the final battle between the
living and the dead image Danish dragon
sent the night King's dragon